merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
le chômage a battu un nouveau record
historique en août plus de vingt mille
nouveaux demandeurs d'emploi sans aucun
emploi 1,5 million sept cent vingt-six
mille 300 demandeurs d'emploi toutes
catégories confondues en france plus de
1 million depuis 2012
il n'ya pas d'amnésie monsieur le faire
chez nous et chez vous il ya un déni
votre ministre du travail dans un bel
élan de langue de bois lors de l'annoncé
de ces chiffres nous expliquent qu'ils
doivent être analysées avec prudence et
que seule la tendance compte à chaque
augmentation il faudrait prendre les
chiffres avec prudence lors des rares
baisses foot les rené vous devriez faire
preuve de plus d'humilité après 36 mois
de haut sur 40 mois d'exercice du
pouvoir
enfin les français ne sont pas dupes ils
savent que la tendance depuis mai 2012
et à une hausse quasi continue elle car
ils en sont les premières victimes
face à cela quelles solutions la fameuse
réforme du code du travail qui vous
annoncé à grand renfort de rapports pour
tenter de convaincre vos amis de gauche
l'ouvragé de robert badinter le rapport
combrexelle rapport terra nova le
rapport de la fondation jean jaurès
tout cela pour quoi vous avais prévenu
pas question de toucher au contrat de
travail
pas question de toucher au temps de
travail pas question de toucher aux
heures supplémentaires
les propositions intéressantes de ces
travaux sont déjà enterrées
chez les républicains notre président
nicolas sarkozy a fait des propositions
percutantes et fondamental ce matin
notre parti organisé une journée dédiée
au travail et nos militants seront
consultés sur nos propositions
alors que vous allez faire un référendum
sur l'éventuel union pour les régionales
à référendum politiciens nous organisons
des consultations sur les vraies
questions de la vie quotidienne des
français s'il a donné la parole au
peuple alors que vous êtes dans la
contorsion nous sommes dans la
proposition monsieur le premier ministre
la réforme du travail que vous allez
présenter sera telle une vraie réforme
sans tabou sans tod m
quant au thème intouchable où allez-vous
à nouveau présenté simple loi qui
agitera momentanément le microcosme
parisien mais ne changera rien ni au
quotidien des français ni à la situation
des enfants il monsieur cherpion
la parole est à madame myriam el khomri
milices du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député cherpion je
l' ai déjà dit les chiffres du mois
d'août ne sont pas satisfaisants mais au
delà des mots et des invectives la
réalité sur le terrain nous montrent que
nous avons des raisons d'être confiant
et je veux en partager avec vous d'abord
en effet la hausse observée en août
intervient après une baisse en juillet
et une stabilisation en juin
ensuite le chômage des jeunes recule et
c'est la première fois qu'il a ce niveau
depuis fin 2012 cela montre bien que la
politique que nous avons mis en place
porte ses fruits
ensuite la reprise de l'activité est
manifeste
la création d'emplois atteint un niveau
inédit depuis quatre ans l'intérim
progresse
le climat des affaires a atteint son
plus haut niveau depuis 2011
l'objectif de ce gouvernement est
d'aller plus vite et plus loin
monsieur le député voit lavé de bonnes
raisons de rester déterminé et combatif
dès demain j'engage une mobilisation
qu'on l'emploi dans les régions pour
mettre en dynamique l'ensemble des
acteurs de la formation de l'emploi et
du monde de l'entreprise concernant la
réforme du code du travail
en effet les propos de nicolas sarkozy
sont claires et très percutant percutant
entre - deux syndicats - deux syndicats
dans l'entreprise remise en cause du
paritarisme moins de protection pour les
salariés c'est l'insécurité sociale de
chacun et la confrontation sociale de
tous nous nous croyons au dialogue
social et nous agissons pour redonner de
la souplesse de la respiration à
négociation dans l'entreprise c'est le
sens du rapport de jean denis
combrexelle
et c'est le sens de la concertation de
jéhovah et les partenaires sociaux qui
feront l'objet d'une loi début 2016 le
droit du travail
c'est le capital des salariés c'est le
sens des lignes rouges la pause et le
premier ministre en effet sur les 35
heures sur le cd i
sur le smic et tout ceci ne sera pas
remis en cause pendant de majorité le
dialogue social c'est l'adn de ce
gouvernement et nous poursuivrons merci
madame la ministre
la parole